kateb hambourg alors la manifestation
est en cours comment ça se passe oui en
effet alors les élus écologistes à paris
ainsi que des militantes féministes sont
regroupés aujourd'hui sur le parvis
elles ont hurlé des slogans pas
d'adjoint à la culture du viol elles ont
également collé un des démos en mettant
matzneff en italie girard à paris
l'objet de leur colère et bien
christophe girard l'adjoint historique à
la culture d'anne hidalgo qui vient
d'être renommé a été entendue dans une
enquête celle visant gabriel matzneff
pour des viols sur mineure alors gabriel
matzneff l'écrivain est connu en tout
cas pour ces son attrait pour les très
jeunes adolescents aussi jeune que 12
ans il s'en était largement à l'époque
répandue dans les médias donc nul ne
pouvait l'ignorer en tout cas christophe
gérard gérard dit qu'il n'était pas au
courant 1 qu'il avait des actes sexuels
avec des mineures extrêmement jeune
en fait ce qui lui reprocher c'est qu'il
a aidé à payer une chambre d'hôtel à
gabriel matzneff en 86 et 87 lorsqu'il
était secrétaire général de la maison il
saint laurent mais même plus tard en
2002 christophe girard avait fait
pression pour que gabriel matzneff
obtiennent une allocation annuelle à vis
du centre national du livre donc ce
soutien irrite énormément les féministes
et les élus écologistes et donc ils
demandent qu'ils soient suspendus au
moins le temps de l'enquète je vous
propose d'écouter une féministe qui a co
organisé ce rassemblement est une élue
écologiste d'avoir été un soutien d'un
pédo criminels notoires pendant des
années et d'aujourd'hui aucune occupé le
poste d'adjoint à la culture à la mairie
de paris qui l'a même la capitale de la
france envoie un signal extrêmement dure
aux victimes de pédocriminalité c'est un
soutien aussi bien financier que moral
et intellectuel
il se dit l'ami de cet homme qui a
bénéficié donc de ce soutien de facilité
financière avant que monsieur girard
soit élu à la mairie de paris quand il
était quand je travaillais pour pierre
bergé yves saint laurent mais depuis que
monsieur girard et à la mairie de paris
il a pu soutenir gabriel matzneff à
plusieurs reprises soit financièrement
soit moralement soit intellectuellement
aujourd'hui ce qu'on réclame c'est une
enquête des services de la ville et on
attend et dans cette attente une
suspension de christophe girac de ses
délégations
parce qu'on ne soutient pas finalement
une forme de complaisance vis-à-vis de
comportement violent à l'égard des
enfants de violences sexuelles on ne
soutient pas la culture du viol et on
m'envoie en très mauvais signal à toutes
les féministes et à toutes les victimes
comme vous l'avez entendu les militants
demandent que l'inspection générale de
la mairie de paris mène une enquête pour
savoir si christophe girard a utilisé sa
position en tant que adjoint à la
culture pour favoriser gabriel matzneff
un peu plus tard que les années 80
ensuite comment réaliser réagissent les
élus socialistes et bien ils font bloc
derrière christophe girard comme par
exemple à emmanuel grégoire qui sait qui
est le premier à jordan hidalgo et qui
s'est exprimé dans la presse à ce sujet
christophe girard pour sa part ne
désavoue pas gabriel matzneff et dit
qu'il ignorait tout il continue à parler
d amour de gabriel matzneff au lieu de
relations qui comme vous le savez tombe
sous le coup du viol et quant à
l'avocate de christophe girard elle a
expliqué qu'elle allait déposer une
plainte avec constitution de partie
civile pour diffamation publique
katia merci à pour toutes ces précisions